nous sommes dans l'atelier plus tôt
l'autre de joseph ici les vieux
climatiseurs les chaises les morceaux de
bois les tuyaux auront une seconde vie
au jour dans une distillerie le
directeur m'interpelle et me dire en
impôts dgi qui ne se vend pas trouvé
nous quelque chose
aujourd'hui quels produits il me dit le
cristal coucou et tout de suite j'ai eu
en tête deux images je lui ai rien dit
je suis rentré chez moi ça se passait
vers 15 heures le lendemain matin à 9
heures je suis arrivé à son bureau avec
deux exemplaires ça a marché pendant des
années ça permet à 18 jeunes de
travailler avec des impayés
parce qu'on a livrée 2000 par mois était
tout le temps wauquiez le score
mon père immo j'avais 8 ans et demi et
ma mère se disait comment je fais avec
ce gamin je n'arrive pas à le retenir il
est comme son père ce avec des machettes
pièce est un ami de mon père a eu l'idée
de nous placer à l'orphelinat et j'ai
fait des choses extraordinaires avec eux
pouvant partir pour être convoyé il
voulait pas m'envoyer alors un jour je
me suis décidé à le feu à
l'orphelinat
oui oui j'ai foutu le feu dans un
vestiaire où ailleurs qu'ils allaient me
renvoyer et l'asmo une raclée en
1972 j'ai des convoqués par le sujet
dédié acteurs du civ mano pour ne pas le
citer et il m'a dit voilà on a un défi
pour droit il ya un monsieur qui vient
martinique pour qu'un jour il a fait des
études pendant sept ans est ce que tu es
capable d'emmagasiner tout ce qu'il a
écrit et au bout d'une semaine j'ai pu
enregistrer toutes ses connaissances et
on a cru y est le jardin musical rançon
sont des escrocs basés sur les gestes
opprimés de l'enfant il va sauter activé
il va pousser il va taper à chaque fois
divertissant et produit des sons alors
si je fais ça je vais en somme c'est une
dalle musicale une dalle musicale c'est
un toboggan musical qui va donner le
leçon moment créole ses meilleures
cliniques avec une bille en bon laisse
tomber dessus
on continue alors je suppose que c'est
aussi un instrument un instrument
c'est une dame une gamme chromatique
vous êtes musicien en fait je peux vous
avez joué 10 trombone c'est ça fait deux
trombones à piston aussi bien molle
pendant 4 à l'orphelinat
encore une chose joseph je sais que vous
restez il vous arrive de rester ici dans
votre atelier des jours durant parfois
un peu plus de 24 heures et que madame
n'est pas toujours très heureuse de cela
l éthologie vous appeler pour venir
déjeuner ou remonter à la maison oui
mais quand je suis dans mon atelier je
n'ai besoin de rien je suis dans un
monde parallèle pas de fatigue pas de
faim pas de soif
le temps pour moi n'existe pas parce que
je deviens le temps
donc du coup vous oublier
ce n'est pas un oubli c'est autre chose
je ne peux pas me l'expliquer mais ça
marche et je crée des choses que je
trouve extraordinaire après et je me dis
dès fois s quintinais que cet outil
n'est que talât qui fait ça je suis
étonné mais ça m'amuse parce que je sais
que ça va recommencer
on peut trophée 1 si on a la foi si on
sait moga nous quittons joseph sont
entrés tous ces objets qui d'après lui a
un jour ou l'autre peuvent toujours
servir à quelque chose